1 démarre le débat à un vaste débat un
grand débat national
l'idée n'a rien de nouveau le premier
c'était en 1993 edouard balladur
fraîchement nommé premier ministre veut
reconquérir les campagnes il lance alors
le grand débat sur l'aménagement du
territoire pour recueillir les
propositions des citoyens de toute la
france des débats des réunions et un
lieu où envoyer des idées les
préfectures monde a son mot à dire et
j'espère que tout le monde va en
profiter
les thèmes touche aux transports aux
services publics à l'enseignement au
tourisme tout ce qui pourra améliorer la
vie des français
sur proposition des français non
seulement pour leurs voisins de ce
convoi de ce que ce qu'on ressent mais
surtout prévoir l'avenir voilà premier
grand débat national
il décide des orientations mais n'a pas
grand effet sur le terrain ne suivant a
lieu en 2003 dans un contexte temple
pour trouver une solution au profond
malaise des enseignants le ministre de
l'éducation lance le grand débat sur
l'école
je ne désespère pas du tout de voir
apparaître dans ce débat national sur
l'école de très bonnes idées qu'on
pourra reprendre dans une loi
d'orientation puisque c'est le but de
l'opération 26000 réunion un million et
demi de participants et en 2004 un
rapport de 637 page
à l'arrivée le débat a nourri la loi
fillon de 2005
quelques mesures comme le renforcement
du soutien scolaire individuelle et
l'enseignement d'une langue vivante dès
le ce1 troisième grand débat national et
pas des moindres en 2009
l'identité nationale l'un des grands
thèmes de campagne présidentielle de
nicolas sarkozy
avec une question qu'est ce qu'être
français aujourd'hui et avant même le
début du débat il fait polémique
un beau débat pourquoi il faut avoir
peur et bien parce que ce débat organisé
en ligne a donné lieu à l'expression
d'opinions plus qu'à des propositions
constructives
nous devons lutter contre cette invasion
voilà ce vers quoi nous allons une
musulmane isation de notre france
un grand débat une grande polémique pour
aboutir à des mesures symboliques une
charte des droits et devoirs pour les
nouveaux français le drapeau apposé sur
chaque école et la déclaration des
droits de l'homme dans toutes les
classes à son tour françois hollande il
ya eu recours à deux reprises en cinq
ans en 2013 pour la transition
énergétique puis pour les accès en 2015
de grands débats nationaux pour peu de
suites politiques
[Musique]